depuis plus de trois ans les autorités
chinoises sont accusés de mener une
répression contre les ouïghours minorité
musulmane installée dans la région de
xinjiang au nord-ouest de la chine et
ouïghours uyghurs goût revoici le sort
réservé à la population bic vous la
diffusion de certaines images où l'on
aperçoit des ouigours yeux bandés et
mains liées et crâne rasé ont choqué le
monde entier et rappelle des images que
l'on ne veut plus voir ce sont un
million de wii gourgues hommes femmes et
enfants qui sont enfermés dans des camps
de redressement
si la communauté internationale condamne
ces actes la chine se défend et
qualifient ces camps de centres de
formation professionnelle pour éduquer
et transformer cette minorité
les etats unis ont imposé décembre son
économie a gravité des faits dans cette
région du gène jones l'on compte à ce
jour près de 3 millions de ouïghours
détenus
l'un d'entre eux a réussi à échapper aux
griffes de cet enfer ce soir omar
bekkali est avec nous après avoir passé
plusieurs semaines dans ces camps il a
décidé de tout nous raconter
merci au maire becali merci d'être là
merci monsieur meerhof d'être là vous
êtes donc son interprète et président de
la belgium yugo association merci d'être
là merci à vous deux merci au mir becali
alors il a passé des semaines danser
dans un des camps de rééducation en
chine pour la seule raison qu'il était
d'être musulman en 2017 il est placé
dans un de ces centres et on est
ressortis traumatisés ce soir vous allez
nous raconter votre histoire dont come
here vous êtes né en chine de parents
ouigours et kazakhes
deux des principales l'ethnie musulmane
en chine pour vous les ennuis commencent
il ya quatre ans en mars 2010 est il et
on qu'arrêter vous êtes arrêté pour des
accusations d' aide au terrorisme qui
n'est pas né en 1966 à un village et
donc jusque 2006
il vivait là-bas donc dans la région
humour et en 2006 il est immigré pour
l'instant d'accord alors il est accusé
de terrorisme des de terrorisme bien sûr
c'est quoi ton corps pourquoi il est
accusé le taureau terrorisme arrêté vous
pouvez répondre donc voilà il donc
depuis 2006 ils vivaient au kazakhstan
tout ça donc
et après il a fait le commerce entre
chine et et les instants puis en 2017
quand il y avait un expo à astana pour
qu'il est parti pour un voyage
commercial mais ses parents c'est
comment sa famille il était toujours là
bas ils sont toujours là voient donc en
faire un voyage commercial
tu l'as fait il voulait juste se
retourner chez ses parents donc on va en
2007 au mois de mars
mais en fait il a été il a été arrêté
juste parce qu'il était musulman c'est
bien sûr voilà quand il est arrivé chez
ses parents donc qu'ils ont arrêtés il
ya les policiers qui sont venus à
l'arrêter emprise plusieurs mails sans
nombre ils ont arrêté alors il est dans
un camp où il subit là il est plutôt
qu'avec les et les chaînes info mire
qu'il portait dans ses comptes il subi
des brimades des humiliations
oui c'est surtout donc c'est pas tout de
suite au camp donc d'abord il était dans
un prison
donc pourquoi il est il montre les
chaînes au sort donc il à rester avec
les chaînes comme ça attaché s'il
pouvait bouger juste maximum et à mettre
trois mois ils vont s'allonger par la
même logique non m il pissait pas vous
laisser la première étape quand il se
dévoile à ses humiliations
c'est fait il frappe qu'il était subi
toutes les tortures qu on peut dire et
après ils l'ont amenée votre part après
ils ont commencé après trois mois et dix
jours que l'on commencé à faire des
commandes de travaux forcés voilà
travaux forcés alors apparaît que en
phase ce qu'on a appris ils font tout
pour le dévier de sa foi pour vous
déviez de votre foi le vendredi jour
saint pour les musulmans et pour force
par exemple à manger du porc pas
seulement le vendredi c'est tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps ouais
c'est cette ils font exprès il
on peut dire comment ils cassent le
moralité de morale de la personne
après quand il est là rien a déjà à
tenir parce que là ils pensent seulement
pour vivre la pression vivant il ya
combien de personnes on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya pour le nombre il
ya toujours une discussion mais entre
trois et cinq millions de personnes
entre 3 et 5 millions actuellement
dans ces camps dans ces camps ils sont 2
millions au total
ils sont douze il reste pendant combien
de temps lorsqu'on qu'il a il est resté
huit mois et moi qu'est ce qui se passe
pour lui là-bas c'est quoi le ils les
mettront donc voilà d'abord il était
dans une une pièce on peut dire donc il
n'y a pas de toilettes et riendeau
donc comme je dis qu'il n'est même pas
bougé donc il est enchaîné
donc même si les petits besoins en
oubliant grand besoin c'est sur un petit
peu de bol ou bassin qui que les autres
comment comment des personnes qui peut
qu'ils ont déjà un peu plus de temps
qu'il est là bas c'est lui qui servit à
la manger tous à temps le même truc
dormir aussi dans le bain truc c'est
pour ça maintenant il sent pas les pieds
qui sent pas les coûts donc il ya plein
de trucs qui sont ils à celui voilà
alors donc au bout de huit mois c'est ça
en novembre 2010 est il est finalement
libéré sans doute grâce à l'intervention
des autorités du kazakhstan où vous
résidez avant la répression
personnellement c'est plutôt c'est plus
comme lui il a raconté le taux sert à
les efforts que sa femme qu'a fait
d'accord sa femme c'est tellement
d'efforts qu'ils ont ils ont sa femme
elle était au kazakhstan dont elle
rester avec les enfants tout ça et avec
l'aide de on a un fils devenu donc pour
le
migration tout ça donc là il a travaillé
dans qu'elle a fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour attendre son histoire ok parce que
lui il était comment il était déjà le
kazakh parce qu'il avait déjà les voilà
même pour ça c'est même avec avec ça ils
l'ont arrêté alors aujourd'hui il n'a
plus de nouvelles de ses parents de ses
trois frères et soeurs restés en chine
why que nous voilà qu il a apporté grâce
à son père d'accord donc après sa
libération il on met toute sa famille
dans le camp et son père il est donc là
toute sa famille actuellement et dans le
camp mais son père il est décédé
n'hésite pas décidés ils étaient tués
torturés dans le camp plus de 70 ans en
2018 il était il était mort lui il a su
cette information seulement après à moi
je ne savais même pas que mais pour le
reste
et il sait pas voilà ici aider les
familles sas et ses frères et soeurs ici
c'est la famille de sa femme
ça sera mon fils ils étaient ils sont
tous étaient dans le camp est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il sait qu'il
s'est installé en turquie
non il est aujourd'hui installé en pole
en hollande d'accord très bien avec sa
femme et ses enfants
ou alors il ne veut pas longtemps ils
les ont réunis ensemble le temps et
aujourd'hui retournera plus jamais en
chine bien sûr il sait pas retourner
parce que sinon il va se sera arrêtée
mais tout ça il ya aussi ils voulaient
marquer on avait parlé tantôt donc ils
voulaient marquer pourquoi il fait tout
ça donc la première chose que quand il
était dans le camp dans une petite pièce
avec tellement de monde et avec des
jeunes tous les commandes de parties de
tenir il ya des personnes
ils ont demandé pour quand ils savaient
que il va sortir que il fait quelque
chose qui peut
faire quelque chose pour eux et
d'essayer de se dessaisir de la série
voit là dessus parce que certains ont
parlé de trois à cinq millions de
musulmans dans ces convois là c'est
incroyable très peu de gens parlent mais
voilà lancés en allait quelques lanceurs
d'alertés vraiment c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe là bas mais c'est tout
c'est encore à cause de l'économie à
cause de l'argent non pas parce qu'il ya
c'est à dire c'est à dire il ya 83
multinationales qui utilisent les
travaux forcés des ouïghours il ya des
milliers de gens il faut avoir des mecs
parce que tous les camps ils sont situés
près de fabrique chez fred des usines de
vêtements d'autrefois là les vêtements
de tous donc la main d'oeuvre la même
pour le fonds ne soit guînes par exemple
cette communauté ne représente plus de
11 millions de personnes en chine à
lewis aux officiellement oui
officieusement on a deux fois plus de
100 millions
plus de 20 millions on dit que jusque 25
payant on a des ego parce que c'est
c'est avec le politique de l'île chinois
pour dire que les commandes pour l'année
sans cela la famille qu'ils peuvent pas
bien sûr juste de ce que les il ya en
chine on nous enfonce ses 1,8 la moyenne
a je crois à la part mais et mais nous
donc généralement c'est les estives
musulmans grenade
pour preuve les familles nombreux c'est
en moyens c'était 5 6 si la ville
l'enfant unique en chine donc forcément
cc c'est compliqué dans la plupart des
rescapés de ces cons sachez le préfèrent
se taire ils ne veulent pas témoigner
par peur de mettre en danger leurs
proches en chine au mir lui il a choisi
justement de parler avec vous voilà
vingt sept sont interprétés il est
également le président de la belge au
mieux leur association
parce que comme vous nous avez dit il
espère ça puisse bouger là bas aucun
gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'a l'a fait c'est
nécessaire pour que on arrête ce
massacre
ça c'est commencer au mois de décembre
en
en amérique donc avec le gouvernement de
trempe
car ils ont fait passer par le parlement
deux américains donc ils ont fait un loi
pour protéger le peuple ouïghour
d'accord après ça ça a commencé à bouger
ça commençait parler un peu est-ce que
ça bouge en ce moment est ce qu'on s'en
moque et oui ça bouge mes parents
voulaient comment ça bouge ça commence
un peu à bouger
oui parce que marseille ira matic ce qui
se passe donc il faut que ça bouge plus
vite
et évidemment il faut sauver le peuple
parce que c'est le avec cette politique
là le gouvernement chinois
il a enfin d'être effacées l'identité
ouïghoure ces surfaces est complètement
lucide alors l'élégance à celle où ont
été construits à partir de 2014 dans le
but d' internes et des centaines de
milliers de musulmans pratiquants
boulgour et kazakhes
il y en aura entre trois et cinq
millions d'onces et quand on dit un
million mais apparemment vous dites
entre 3 et 5
officiellement ils sont internés dans
ces cons c'est une vaste campagne d'anti
terrorisme visant les islamistes dont
qui sert de sète cedex clusaz lamentable
voilà pour les internes y c'est l'
esclavage moderne c'est fou oui mais
c'était devenu un délit en 2014 la
pratique de la religion musulmane
ils sont servis de ça c'est qu'en fait
les ouigours sont extrêmement importants
dans le nord-est du pays
comme vous l'avez dit vous êtes plus de
12 millions 15 millions et cetera ils
auront balancé il ya 56 nationalités
différentes en chine il faut savoir si
un immense pays et ils ont balancé
l'ethnie and i'll contre eux il y a
commencé à avoir des émeutes très très
violente entre eux et donc on a
commencéà dans calais finaliser ce que
pour les autorités chinoises être
musulman c'est être un terroriste c'est
un délit voilà ce que dit le mercator
s'indigne un journaliste chinois qui
avait pu filmer discrètement l'intérieur
d'un sac en construction on découvrait
que ça ressemblait plus à une prison
qu'à une école comme voudraient le faire
croire le gouvernement chinois regarder
un journaliste chinois a pu filmer ces
quelques images en caméra cachée c'était
en août dernier le bâtiment était encore
en construction depuis plus de mille
personnes y sont enfermés à l'intérieur
on découvre des dortoirs qui ressemble à
des cellules de prison
à chaque étage trois salles de classe
comme celle-ci et au mur des slogans
suivez les directives du président chez
jean ping sur le socialisme aux
caractéristiques chinoises pour une
nouvelle ère c'était des images d' art
et qui avaient été diffusés à l'époque
on son os mire on sent très très triste
très touché ça fait comme une semaine
qu'il est sorti de ce conte trois ans à
la raison et ont consenti d'aliermont
yeux on le sent très ému bien sûr ma vie
il dit que s'il était humiliée donc ça
s'il peut pas oublier ça donc
et surtout il m'avait raconté tentent
eux aussi quand son père est le thème
comment décidé aussi de sa mère qui l'a
dit parce qu'il savait quand elle était
au kazakhstan il a vu qu'il a eu une
communication et sa mère l'a dit tu peux
témoigner parce qu'il commençait déjà à
donner au kazakhstan quel doux à toute
façon on va mourir
donc il faut donc s'étaler jusqu'au bout
des ongles
il a donné la parole à sa mère et où
j'entends l'été ensemble dans le camp
c'est pour ça il tient son parole est
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'ils voient la
main ces envois la saison vi et c'est au
mir aujourd'hui votre combat c'est
d'essayer voilà de sauver le maximum de
personnes qui sont dans ces cons d'avoir
ans je te rapprocher des cantiques et le
retour de brian rich ricci évidemment
c'est pour ces gens pour ce peuple donc
pour qu'ils créent ce sens
envie au moins pour qu'ils peuvent vivre
en commun un être humain quoi c'est pas
trop demander
aujourd'hui pour lui ce ne pourra plus
jamais avoir une vie normale il est il
est traumatisé il ait kaci que sa
famille aussi puisqu'il vit avec sa
famille où les idiots hollande il arrive
à un ici voilà deux de penser à autre
chose parfois où c'est toujours dans cet
esprit de combat mais voilà il dit
depuis trois ans il est sorti il a juste
attendu que son père qui décide et un
pour le reste pour sa mère pour ses
proches pour ses frais pour ses soeurs
il s'est même pas qu'ils sont en vie ou
non où ils sont donc
donc voilà ici il dit il pense tout le
temps à ça parce que en gros on peut
dire le camp il était quand il est sorti
salon les s'il était libéré aux instants
à la partie requise instants après ça
c'est l'idée qui tient quand même deux
responsables que toute sa famille qui
était ami dans le camp à cause de lui
donc voilà c'est ça qui tient et il peut
pas lâcher maintenant il veut aller
jusqu'au bout aujourd'hui il travaille
au long non il est arrivé par longtemps
donc alors que maintenant on apprend
encore là d'accord ils arrivent à s'en
sortir à vivre avec sa famille au début
il était tout seul sa femme il est resté
au en turquie maintenant il ya quelques
mois vraiment récent que l'on réunit et
maintenant il existe un peu mieux
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'il a envie de
dire à emmanuel macron
voir si l'on regarde le président
français ce qui est ce qu'on a là là le
poids pour essayer de faire bouger les
choses je sais que les américains
essaient de faire bouger les choses
aussi ou est-ce qu'il ya rien à faire
que le gouvernement chinois ne bougera
pas à prendre un seul jeune homme
regarde passer quelques nouveaux donc il
souhaite que ma combien vaut aux autres
dirigeants
il veut dire que voilà il faut arrêter
cette gêne aussi bien sûr donc il faut
agir plus vite possible pour sauver les
vies des gens pour qu'ils peuvent vivre
humainement
normalement il dit que c'est tout le
dirigeant ensemble en commun seront
comme à obtenir il peut faire bouger les
choses voilà bouger les choses soient
tournoi merci en tout cas merci monsieur
meerhof d'avoir été avec nous merci
merci à vous j'aimerais remercier au
mire également ce qu'on peut le
remercier
merci d'avoir été là j'espère que ça va
faire bouger les choses
votre témoignage qu'on va relier bien
sûr sur les réseaux et femmes ont été
très touchés par votre témoignage et par
votre voilà en montagne ce soir a ajouté
encore comme le l'émission on appelle
touche pas à mon poste on peut dire
aussi touche pas mon choix à mon peuple
ouïghour exactement c'est vrai qu'on va
le lancer
on va le lancer on va lancer le hashtag
dont va lancer sur les raisons merci au
mir et merci monsieur ehrhoff d'avoir
été avec mais on a su être patient et on
espère on va tout faire pour que ça
bouge en tout cas avec à notre petite
échelle mais c'est vrai qu'ici tout le
monde bouge ça pourra peut-être essayer
d'améliorer les choses assez rapide
parce que chaque jour qui passe c'est
des personnes qui meurent bien entendu
et c'est vraiment un drame qui se passe
en chine actuellement